this is awesomely perfect burly just
moved in with his rich girlfriend and we
need help with the rent
we have a couple house rolls though yeah
sure of course you can't use the front
door you have to climb in through the
back window
no personal phone conversations if you
ever speak to me in spanish please use
the formal uth dead
and no electricity after 6 pm she's
joking
okay you can use as much free
electricity as you want it's free
a couple more rules if you ever watch a
sad movie you have to wear mascara so we
can see whether or not you've been
crying
there's no noise a lot on mondays and no
tv after breakfast
it's lying again because it's hard to
tell
the internet's not working ben we need
your help
guys i've told you how to do it you just
unplug the router and then you plug it
back in again
i guess i'll do it
still not working well give it a minute
good
okay it's working
i actually think you look really good
except for the
stick up your butt what do you think
druid was it nathaniel
ellis man i feel like these interns do
not respect or like me at all
honestly you could loosen up a bit on
the font stuff
and everything in general oh wow look at
that
did you draw that uh nope i didn't no no
no it's really good i mean you're
a you're a great artist uh i can't do
this
look i don't care who you're related to
i'm your boss and you can't keep
disrespecting me like this man
i didn't draw it your daughter did it
what her april's not my daughter she's
my friend does everyone think she's my
daughter
whatever point is she would never do
that to me
sorry dad
here's that report you wanted boss it's
funny because it has 30 different fonts
on it and you only like one
do you like it yeah it's hilarious
okay i'm sorry i drew those pictures of
you i was just messing around
you may not take this seriously but this
job is important to me
and by the way you should take it
seriously because i asked you to come
work here because
i thought you'd enjoy it and i think
you're smart but you have to have some
semblance of professionalism
and i need you to give like even a 15
effort
12 15 for god's sake i'm asking 15
effort it's not supposed to be a
negotiation
fine i'm sorry
15. yeah
i love cup gangs alice hates you
annie has herpes if what's your problem
my problem is you smell us
ben told you to finish the website and
if you don't do it i swear to god i'm
gonna murder you
in your sleep i know where you live 14th
street right i'm gonna get a melon
baller and scoop your eyes out and eat
them
and your congressman uncle's gonna have
to buy you a dog to drag your eyeless
face around do you understand me yes
do it okay
thank you all for your hard work now
stay cool
it's a hot one out there today that's
right you could practically cook an egg
on the sidewalk
terrific
okay let's make sure we're ready for the
strategy session tomorrow okay
hey we're still gonna assassinate him
right don't say that
ben
what the hell is he doing
look
what am i looking at he's not doing
anything that's the point this morning
he got in and sat down in there and has
been staring straight ahead doing
nothing
he's a robot he's not a robot he's just
thinking he's got a lot on his mind
yeah like one one zero one must eat
babies for fuel
why would a robot need to consume
organic matter
sorry you know what they probably put a
tv in there and he's watching old
speeches to bone up or something let's
go see
congressman here is the briefing packet
for our strategy meeting later
excellent thank you
anything else i can do for you no sir
all systems are
operational great stay cool hot one out
there today
thank you congressman
yo you ready to go why yes i am april
let's go now what's wrong with you
[Laughter]
wonderful hey be careful out there
traffic is
nuts on the streets and roads oh no they
got you
terrific hey i'm hungry let's go eat
some batteries
i mean human food hey uh batteries i
mean human food sounds good to me
wonderful
let's go dude 30 years from now when
you're on your deathbed what are you
gonna remember
organizing files or taking a spontaneous
road trip to surprise leslie
yeah you know what all right i'm in you
know we might be able to sneak out early
you get snacks i'll bring music we'll
jam out to some sweet tunage you know
what
this is awesome actually no i don't want
to go anymore oh
okay just kidding see you in 10 minutes
okay
just kidding we're not going
road trip so we're going yes
oh i'm excited to bond a little with
april she's like the little sister i
never had
because the little sister i do have is
normal and
not terrifying
good lord it is hot yes mercy me
living in this town's like living in the
devil's butt crack
i'm almost out of gas they tore on the
highway
now the gps says we should take 495 to
270.
but check out this cool alternate route
oh my god that is so interesting to me
because i'm a map
salesman data had never felt this way
before of course data
had never felt anything before but
captain picard couldn't help but note
the smile that crept over his mechanical
but lifelike face i'm gonna murder you i
understand just one sec
as they walked down the hall into the
bridge
soundtrack to pulp fiction soundtrack to
singles
soundtrack to gross point blank why do
you have so many soundtracks
oh well uh i kind of look at it like
it's your favorite director's making a
mixtape just for you
oh oh here's something
benji's cool time summer jams mix oh no
i
probably don't want to listen to that
yes i want to listen to you i want to
listen to it
we don't need to april
oh here i go here i go here i go again
bro
really don't judge me okay
whoa it's moving it's moving what
yes finally
no no no no no no no
what no we're out of gas
please just steer be stronger
that's a great road trip we made it 40
feet yeah well at least it took a
million hours
and it was 180 degrees and we starved to
death so
fun
hey how about next weekend we fly to
pawnee
tickets are on me really that would be
awesome definitely
never mind i don't feel like it
what oh my god see how it feels
why would any of you think i would hurt
leslie you're all my friends too
uh sorry i can't go through with this i
was gonna pull a prank
no yeah i hired these guys in ski masks
to kidnap us and i was gonna pretend to
be a hero they were gonna shoot me and
drive the van into the river and that's
when the divers would go in pull you
guys out of the water and i would be
standing on the shore like hey
get pranked much what the i even got
these squibs from a special effects guy
and i was gonna
say this code word that's when i would
push this button no no
oh my god you got blood all over me
thank you i mean it
ben that was amazing really best prank
ever
well i never thought i'd say this but i
think i know what's going on
in your head oh well then welcome to the
terror dome why are you so into helping
me right now
because i'm finally doing what i love
and i know how hard it is to get to that
place
and i want you to be happy because
you're my friend no i'm not i've never
cared for you
wait wait
you're behaving very strangely
you